the Joe Rogan experience let's talk
about endurance so there are different
aspects to endurance and so there's
cardio and there is the local the
peripheral endurance and the muscles
muscular endurance
so first let's discuss how do we develop
cardio let's discuss how we develop
endurance in the muscle the best the
healthiest way to develop your cardio is
just steady-state exercise like running
in a particular particular speed that's
not too fast that's very simple that's
so that's way to develop cardio for most
people it is for most people it is and
so here's what's happening what's
happening is the heart is stretching
when you increase your heart rate up to
a certain point the heart starts
stretching more and it stretches more
and more so that increases the stroke
volume so pretty much you get a bigger
heart and that's good that works up to
not quite 90 percent of heart rate when
you start redlining your heart rate when
you start getting to 90% and higher the
heart does not have time to relax fully
so it really pretty much is twitching so
you're no longer really stretching that
hard so you want to be training at the
metabolic intensity that's much lower
something we can pretty much sustain a
conversation so like say you're running
and talking to your body that's what you
want to stay to develop endurance that
what to develop to stretch your heart
that's the basic method so that's one
method hmm so the second method is
interval training so and the interval
training for the heart was developed by
Germans decades ago and these guidelines
still stand so here's what they figured
out they figured out that your well we
know that this various systems and you
body have inertia so for instance note
is that when you're running hard and you
stopped your heart still beating hard
and then maybe 10 seconds after there's
a sudden drop
right there sir is that inertia so the
Germans figured out if you get your
heart rate up to about 85 to 90 percent
which is it's hard but it's still not
maximal and then you switch to walking
or jogging so the heart is still beating
and so does this extra volume of blood
is moving in the stretches the heart so
it works really well so you can use the
intro method as well but it's it was
found it's used best after after a
period of steady state training it's
very demanding on the body and it's not
it's just it's too easy to have problems
with the heart if you start using it
prematurely then there's also such a
thing as high heart rate under heavy
loads so in this particular case we're
talking about dynamic exercises so as
dynamic exercise running bicycling
skiing even light callable swings that's
dynamic exercise when you start doing
static exercises let's say you're trying
to do squats heavy squats for you know
to get your cardio so to say that's not
the best idea because that interferes
with the blood flow that it's something
called after load versus preload the
heart gets thicker instead of the heart
gets you know gets stretched and bigger
so it's not the optimal way to train the
heart you can again the simple way you
can use dynamic exercise in interval
type training or repeat training in this
case to train your heart is to do an
exercise that's dynamic in nature to
raise your heart rate to about let's say
8090 percent which would be 80 to 90
percent it would be where you can say
maybe a couple words you know you're not
you're not dying yet you can still
answer a question and then you just walk
around and you do it again so that's a
simple way of how much time walking
around that depends that totally depends
on who you are to bend semester how fast
you know heart rate drops back down what
do you wanna like is there a number do
you want to keep it in the 140s the 150s
is dependent upon your age okay in this
particular case you would do you would
drop it down the original guidelines
were done for young people those 120
hundred 30 beats are you're talking
about 60 65 percent and pretty much if
you're just looking at being able to
pass the talk test which means you can
talk you know short sentences hmm I can
speak in a short something like that
right so for example you do a set of 10
swings really powerful with a kettle
bell walk around a little bit when you
feel that you can speak again you do it
again do it again so that's a simple way
of doing that but the heart is only a
very small part of endurance so we
definitely need to do some cardio for
health and athletes definitely need to
do for their performance but what we
really need to focus on is needed
mitochondria so mitochondria in the in
the muscle cell so that's where energy
is being converted aerobic Li which
means efficiently so if you look at the
way your muscle uses energy so you will
get this energy with food converted it
goes down eventually the final currency
so to say is something called ATP but
it's only you know you only have it for
a few seconds so it has to be reloaded
so we have three main energy systems so
have the creatine phosphate system it's
very powerful but it's only can do you
know go for just some seconds and it's
clean burning we have aerobic system
that's not powerful at all but it's
longer-lasting and we have the
glycolytic system that's kind of in
between that dumps a lot of acid and
other fatigue metabolites in there so
what we want to do as we want to develop
this mitochondria in our muscles it's
easy to do in slow fibers and it's a
little more involved in fast fibers I'll
tell you how we can do that but it can
be done so what we're looking for
instead of trying to trash the muscle
with acid
we are trying to train in a way that to
produce less acid and then only before
the competition right before the
competition couple weeks out you do a
couple of kind of a smokers like that to
get yourself used to that that's thing
so the way we develop mitochondria which
means make your muscle oxidative make
your muscle enduring and not polluting
in slow fibers it's simply moving right
below anaerobic threshold so anaerobic
threshold
it's that intensity at which you you
know acid is accumulating just up to a
certain point it stays at that steady
state and you can keep disposing of that
for a while for quite a while as soon as
you go above it very rapidly you crash
so running right below that aerobic
threshold is the primary training method
for endurance athletes and how do you
know that you ran the threshold when you
fail in the TOC test that's a simple way
to do that and it's very interesting
that endurance athletes even though who
are not necessarily well-educated they
kind of tend to grab it taste or that
intensity and so what happens is we are
producing just small amounts of acid and
the body finally is able to you know
produce less and less so that's how we
train our robic I'm sorry that's how we
train mitochondria in slow fibers for
fast fibers has become something more
interesting so the conditions the
conditions for making the mitochondria
be able to handle more traffic without
producing as much acid is push them just
to the edge of acidosis just just to the
edge and do it over and over and over so
professor burka sanski back in the 80s
together that's a guy who invented
plyometrics and so on so he figured out
so here's what we do
imagine that you are sprinting lesser
he's sprinting for five seven seconds
and then you are just walking and you're
sprinting again and you're just walking
but you're doing that you're measuring
your blood lactate and it still keeps
below the threshold and you sustain that
for let's say 40 minutes so think of
this for a second
so you're sprinting very intensely but
you you stop before you start burning
you get to the point of just light mask
you're fatigued and you do it over and
over and over so if we talk about the
coaching terminology its repeat training
versus interval training so what is
interval training partners you'll have
to take a step to the side so the three
types of rest periods between your sets
whether you're running lifting whatever
so there's a stress period that means
that you will have a harder time to do
the same thing or you will not be able
to repeat it right
that's interval training there is the
super compensation period which means if
you wait extra long time you'll perform
even better like for example if you do a
set of pull ups wait for 15 minutes you
might be able to do more 15 minutes
later and there is the ordinary period
which is that you'll be able to repeat
it over an hour so that's in coaching
speakers called repeat training repeat
verses interval so we're trying to
sustain that same level of performance
for 40 minutes let's say so that's an
example of how we develop mitochondria
fast which fibers and the same thing we
can do with kettlebell swings the same
thing you can do work in a heavy bag and
so on and so forth
[Applause]